sonny gray has pitched better than his
numbers and it feels like he's largely
grown outing to outing yeah i think you
know you look at his numbers the one and
four record
you know that's not indicative of what
this guy brings to the team what sonny
gray can be a strikeout pitcher and
those numbers spike
against the brewers
this is his 11th start against milwaukee
a 2-7-0 era
at lifetime against the brewers lark he
is striking out 12 per nine this year's
brewers also strike out more than most
teams
and there's his first strikeout of the
day off speed down and away swinging a
miss
3-2 got a piece and that'll be strike
three a couple of k's for sonny gray
houser has been dialed in one earned run
over his last 10 innings it's been
split between the
starting rotation and the bullpen but
doing a really great job and one thing
we look for in this one is the ability
to get balls on the ground 60
is what he is inducing so let that
defense work behind him guys stay on
your toes
joey vado here from the fans nice roar
as he was announced
[Music]
will lift one to center field camping
under it is jbj as hauser gets out of
the first getting trouble
shaw adamus and bradley scheduled
against sunny grave
and shaw you can see that on that
breaking ball down and in
shaw really overmatched by sonny gray
and he goes down on strikes
put out complete sunny gray with four
k's through two
eugenio suarez coming to the plate
sends one into left coming on is yellows
for the catch and out number one here in
the second
that's a tremendous play there christian
yelling stealing a single
not an easy read for an outfielder
because you have to make a decision i
mean immediately i think there's a
little top spin on that which helps but
you got to recognize that as the left
fielder to know hey that top of the spin
is going to make it drop down so i can
go ahead and commit here's shogo
second and third one out
payoff
into center field base hit barnhart
scores and the reds take a one-nothing
lead
akiyama with a nice line drive up the
middle my question is
why does not farmer
score on this line drive
it was hit well
because jackie bradley jr got to it very
quickly that's the answer
tomas vera athletic trainer is out derek
johnson pitching coach right behind
it came
as gray was looking at warming up
now watch for him to start stretching
[Music]
felt something there now remember he had
the back injury in spring training that
slowed his start to the season
you know you expect sunny gray
to go out there and give you some
innings because this bullpen has just
been taxed
but you also got to have a
healthy sunny grade
he's coming out oh no he's coming out
sonny gray is done
sean doolittle
as
it appears he is ready to go
as there is a drive hit into deep left
field and that's out of here for avasail
garcia and this game is tied first pitch
missed just a little bit with that
fastball and tried to go back in there
again and garcia who rarely takes the
first pitch
jumps all over the second one he sees
and welcomes rudely sean doolittle to
this ball game take a look at this
fastball doesn't get it in there far
enough and
arms fully extended and you can see the
look on doolittle's face
i'm not supposed to be in this ball game
this earlier
he knew it and garcia knew it
a couple of walks couple of wild pitches
and opportunity knocks here for the brew
crew as christian yelich
on the ground double play chance india
farmer
for the double play but urius will
score and the brewers will
take a two to one lead here in the fifth
there's william thomas
two outs and the base is empty
sharp ground ball nice pick by suarez to
his feet out hey eugenio suarez diving
to his left and it's a one two three
sixth for amir garrett two men out with
suarez the runner at first here's kyle
farmer two strike pitch
and on the ground diving stops shaw and
from his knees got him at first oh what
a play by travis shaw
over at third
grand to the backhand i mean travis
shaw's just popping up all over
incredible use the turf there
and a nice job we'll go back as that was
going up the line
reach in
reel it in and sooner is absolutely
pumped we have seen travis make some big
plays over there add another one tonight
once again you got the speed
of jackie bradley jr out there
tapped back to brock throw to third tag
on bradley they got him
suarez on the cover brock the dime
big time team up to cut down the man in
scoring position now they're just gonna
intentionally walk christian yelich and
load the bases for avi garcia
and there's a change-up bouncer over the
mound indian knocks it down but there's
no play as peterson will score infield
single for avi garcia
as the brewers now have a two run lead
second rbi of the night for abisael
garcia
gets the change up but it's a pitch on
the outside corner was a pretty good
pitch by brock
i'd say the contact obviously is there
by garcia but a bit lucky as well in
terms of placement
go ahead and intentionally walk omar
narvaez so runners in first and second
as travis shaw steps to the plate the
1-0
and that is wrapped into right center
field a base hit and that is going to
get to the wall taylor's in
narvaez rounding third he's digging for
home here's the throw not in time
and a big two run ninth inning double
from travis shaw and it's a five to one
ball game now you've got the heart of
your order coming up winker castellanos
and vado it would take quite a comeback
but certainly not beyond the realm of
possibility trying to make it a
five-game run two-strike pitch swung on
and missed and the brewers do in fact
take the opener